Rita Ora sets the record straight on the
Beyonce jay-z trauma when vana Rita
spills all the lemonade as the latest
cover model for cosmopolitan UK
September issue the British singer gets
candid about where she stands with the
power couple after settling her lawsuit
with former record label jay-z's Roc
Nation in May and that controversial
line from be sorry song he better call
back it the good hair 25 year old pop
star was attacked by yon say's beehive
when she wore a lemon bralette and was
quickly accused of being the Becky
Beyonce was singing about on her album
despite rumors Rita praised the couple
telling Cosmo quote I'm still happy I've
had this incredible experience jay is
one of my idols and beyonce is obviously
the queen of life I'll never not
appreciate the experience I had with
them and the things I've seen Rita adds
that J and B are great mentors but when
asked about how close she is to the pair
now she didn't go into detail simply
saying I look up to them a lot